[Música]
hablamos ahora de salud en directo
américa de france 24 más romeros a la
con nosotros en el estudio maria
llegamos al fin de semana y vamos a
hablar del coi largo jala este fin de
semana sea largo pero no lo único que es
largo para nosotros desde el kobe y en
los últimos datos que tenemos sobre esta
condición cómo se define este kobe largo
mar buenos días raúl o pues se define de
muchas formas ahora vamos a ver cómo hay
menos consenso alrededor de lo que es el
común largo de lo que son los fines de
semana largo realmente básicamente es
cuando después de una infección por el
virus que provoca la enfermedad del
covent 19 todavía hay síntomas meses
después sin embargo no hay mucho
consenso de hecho por ejemplo la
definición de la oms y la definición de
los centros de control y prevención de
enfermedades de eeuu no coinciden según
la oms se empieza a contar después de
tres meses de que la persona haya tenido
los primeros síntomas de kobe 19 y estos
síntomas tienen que durar al menos dos
meses más en cambio desde los cdc estos
centros de control de enfermedades de
eeuu su definición ellos empiezan a
contar después de las cuatro semanas de
que una persona se haya contagiado es
decir que un mes después de haberse
contagiado inicialmente del virus
todavía aparezcan estos síntomas de esto
empieza como a mostrar esta confusión
incluso en algunos casos podríamos
llamar caos que existe alrededor de esta
condición y de esta enfermedad que
todavía es muy desconocida también por
ejemplo alrededor de los síntomas no hay
algunos consejos en ese sentido se
calcula que alrededor del 50 por ciento
de las personas afectadas reportan
sentir una fatiga constante es el
síntoma más prevalente pero también ahí
alrededor de un 20 por ciento de estas
personas que dicen tener cobit largo que
hablan de pérdida de memoria de
problemas de concentración otros en
menor medida problemas pulmonares falta
de aire y igual que la misma enfermedad
del coi 19 realmente estos síntomas
aunque en menor prevalencia se pueden
repartir por todo el cuerpo hay gente
que también puede hablar de problemas de
piel los síntomas gastrointestinales un
es que el coe de 19 es una enfermedad
todavía como dices falta muchísimo por
estudiar más se sabe cuántas personas
sufren de este código pues se tiene una
idea pero de nuevo no está claro yo creo
que esa frase es la que más vamos a
repetir a lo largo de este
así es nada está claro uno de los
últimos estudios también de estos ac/dc
estadounidenses muestran que
aproximadamente se puede calcular con un
20 por ciento de personas que se han
contagiado de covent 19 luego tienen
cobit largo es un estudio bastante
sólido porque usa una base de datos
gigante pero que no deja de tener
también algunas limitaciones y de hecho
es importante recordar que hay datos que
disienten estadísticas británicas por
ejemplo hablan de un 13 por ciento 13 y
medio de personas contagiadas de kobe
que luego desarrollan kobe largo otros
estudios llega analizar que es hasta la
mitad de las personas que se han
contagiado pero por qué es tan complejo
pues porque si no hay por ejemplo un
consenso alrededor de la definición
tampoco hay un consenso alrededor de los
síntomas es muy difícil tener unos
parámetros en los cuales medir pues
cuánta gente realmente está afectada
pero sin duda no es poca estamos
hablando de un porcentaje relativamente
alto ahora marc como puede ser que este
virus se convierta en una enfermedad tan
larga si es uno de los grandes misterios
que faltan por resolver de nuevo no está
claro pero se manejan tres hipótesis que
vamos a explicar
se trata de los coágulos de sangre que
se pueden generar durante la infección
por covite 19 se ha visto por ejemplo en
algunas personas sobre todo en niños que
tenían problemas para respirar después
de una infección que parte de sus
pulmones no estaban funcionando bien y
se debía a causa de que no estaban
recibiendo una buena irrigación por
precisamente esos coágulos de sangre y
daños pues en las venas que transportan
la sangre hasta los principales órganos
se piensa que si puede pasar en los
pulmones puede pasar también en otros
órganos otra de las explicaciones es que
queden restos del virus no lo que sería
una infección persistente se ha visto
también en tejidos de personas que han
tenido este comité que luego tienen kobe
largo que hay rastros de rn a de arn en
español del virus del cob y de 19 y que
entonces pues esto podría seguir dañando
órganos y pues funciona el
funcionamiento del cuerpo en general
pero bueno sigue siendo una hipótesis la
última es que es una reacción exagerada
del sistema inmune algunos estudios
también han mostrado que personas con
kobe largo tienen un sistema inmune en
alerta constante o que en el momento de
la infección pues la inflamación
también les dañó órganos sin embargo
todo esto son estudios muy pequeños
todavía no se han hecho a gran escala y
no tienen una significación estadística
suficientemente importante marc pero a
futuro hablemos digamos a un largo plazo
sabemos cómo prevenir esta enfermedad de
nuevo la mala noticia es que no sabemos
con bien cómo prevenirla no sabemos bien
cómo tratarla tenemos algunas
indicaciones sobre factores de riesgo
que nos pueden ayudar no en ese sentido
por alguno por por un lado se sabe que
afecta más a mujeres que a hombres ese
es uno de los primeros factores de
riesgo también afecta más a personas con
que hayan tenido un cuadro grave de la
enfermedad o personas que hayan tenido
condiciones de salud previas por otro
lado parece que la variante o micro no
produce menos casos de kobe grave de
kobe perdón largo a largo plazo y que
también estar vacunado puede ayudar a
que se desarrollen menos casos así que
por ahora pues seguir intentando no
contagiarse y vacunándose pero la verdad
es que hay mucho desconocimiento la
parte positiva con la que queríamos
terminar es que en realidad estamos
presenciando en vivo y en directo cómo
se construye la ciencia esto que está
pasando con el commit largo ha pasado
con muchísimas otras enfermedades que
ahora ya conocemos mejor vamos viendo
como esas estudios pequeños se van
convirtiendo en datos grandes hasta que
finalmente haya un consenso general en
el mundo científico y los expertos sobre
qué es esta condición por qué y cómo
tratarla y qué pueden pasar años son
marc pues muchísimas gracias como
siempre por toda la información de salud
feliz fin de semana nos vemos ya el
lunes con más información y pasamos a
saludar a nuestro segundo invitado el
día